welcome welcome to your mom's house
[Music]
fucking come over on the side is I'm
taking shit
[Music]
yeah that's really good I laughed the
whole time
al Ezz Oh Ali's such a champ at these
he's really good at them in that
diarrhea have fun haters I gotta tell
you I was in Houston yesterday and
machines within has taken over Poston
people love it it's a smash hit song it
is I've got some news about that coming
up with oh my gosh I can't wait exciting
I'm coming into my home stretch what a
year of touring goodness holy shit
thank you everybody came to all the
shows this year really was a blast for
me once-in-a-lifetime experience to go
on a tour like that you know the theater
tour was pretty cool here's how its
winding down for me this comes out
Wednesday I'm in Riverside tonight at
the Fox I think it's called the Fox
Theatre and then they released 50 more
tickets sold out Saturday the 25th it's
gonna be such a crazy show everybody we
know in LA has texted us yeah it is such
that is such a huge deal gene I cannot
wait for that I'm excited for it yeah
big deal big deal gene find of a big
deal if you're playing The Wiltern well
I don't know about that but I am excited
to do it
and then don't be modest your jeans are
extra tight then a couple weeks ago to
fart Nick I haven't been there in a
while
yeah fart next Arizona as opposed to I'm
going to do the other farting just for
shows at stand-up live I think two are
sold out already great venue great venue
that is a great club it's like it's a
club but it's basically a small theatre
so just Friday Saturday that's December
I think 8th and 9th that is it like I
said I think two are already sold out
amazed and that's gonna be in a few
weeks it will be gone and then Hawaii
December 14th in Maui and December 16th
the Hawaii theatre in Honolulu think
he's got Maui Maui mommy mommy mommy
mommy mommy
so yeah December 14th and 16th have E
and then that's it the gods are not
going on the road for a while yeah
what are you gonna do g.od with all that
time I don't know I'm gonna do an L a
show like a small show probably in
January maybe February a small show
meaning like like to start off a new
thing yeah local thing it's exciting
cause that's when you're special I find
out today minded my date oh yeah crazy
the release date powerful of my
disgraceful new special what a great
what a great thing yeah yeah yes all
right guys Pasadena Icehouse January
12th I'll be headlining night show let
me put some friends on there to make it
a really fun night wellthey February 2nd
3rd shark licks titty in puta puta
wiseguys get it wiseguys comedy club
February 23rd Colusa at the Colusa Club
in there I've done that yeah is cuckoo
is somewhere like I want to say it's
kind of close to Sacramento like in that
area though the balls in the sack yeah
ball sack
March 30th and 31st Portland horrigan at
hiriam comedy
very excited to go back there why do you
say that you know I just have a
pronunciation thing yeah sometimes I
can't say the words right tone okay
anything else no but I lost where I was
before well the tickets go to Christina
P online for any of those tickets for
mine go to Tom Segura calm and hit the
tour page don't Google the city go to
always to the artist page you know why
because that's how you avoid the
scalpers and the craic people hit me up
can't believe you're selling 150 dollar
ticket like dude that's somebody else
trying to make money from you don't do
it get the regular normal priced tickets
they're like 30 bucks 35 bucks or
something man they're not 125 dollars
anyways just thought I'd throw that out
there anything else shop re christmas is
coming up I hope you guys are doing your
shopping on our stores our merch stores
oh yeah there's a letters yeah there's a
new I guess I'll say it now is a new
item oh just hit the store it's pretty
exciting
I um thought I was going to do this for
it but well I'm sorry I didn't know you
had a whole thing
yep then machines within shirt oh yeah I
got the wrong volume on it shoes with
thin machines with thin
yeah so I'm very excited and also this
is also corresponding with a massive
sale because we're doing Thanksgiving
Black Friday whatever that is sales so
if you go to the site we have a huge
sale going on starting I think it's on
Friday so make sure you check it out we
have Santa Claus is black Santa Claus is
Latino Santa Claus is Asian and a bunch
of Christmas so we have a Santa Claus
wears jeans hat and sweater 100% of the
profits from the sweater which is almost
sold out it's all going to Children's
Hospital of Los Angeles awesome so yeah
that's very cool that that's the only
thing by the way if you get Santa Claus
wears jeans sweater it won't be on sale
because it's a charity item so the other
thing so we can give them more money
yeah the other things will all be on
sale so there's that I think we should
call it brown Friday Brown Friday that's
a really good point but what if you ship
blood then it is kind of black and red
Friday
wait black brown and red this reminds me
I I also did Pete Holmes as podcast oh
the porn star no Pete Holmes the
comedian star of the HBO show crashing
OH
he has you made it weird podcast I did
it it's out today so if you are palm
cast coming up and then he's really good
at interviewing yeah I want to I want to
listen to you I never listen to you on
other podcasts it's funny because
afterwards you like how that person got
me to open up they just have like a
really I don't know it's almost like a
subtle way of this you know engaging you
and getting you to yeah be more open and
yeah yeah and did you go I mean he's a
really nice guy did he give you a
massage after did you guys yeah yeah no
we took a bath release we took a bath
yeah yeah I have some podcast news I'm
on Marc Maron's today whose poem KO his
podcast this week his episode and then
dr. drew I saw by the way a few messages
from last week yeah people riding in
there like did she just say pacifically
and they were like that how does she say
that so long I like when yeah when some
people don't they're not in on the joke
so no and you're like guys come on
people were at lecture I know how she
sang pacifically yeah Hilaire alright
alright it's time to get into this we go
gene here we go
I just want to know how we got here
not to offend anybody out there but I
just walked by some
jeans or out jeans holes in them all cut
up
who is Randy don't bring anyone love
into this welcome to your mom's house
[Music]
yeah I'm offended at those jeans I just
realize that you're wearing a Jean our
Jean hooded sweatshirt I don't know but
it is my favorite I'd audible it's
comfortable it's the right thickness
level it's not too thick it's soft and I
like it cuz it's like a why I made
reference but it's not it's not loud
unless they know and it's hilarious when
I wear it I like to wear it on airplanes
it's perfect it's got pockets a hood
yeah Anna I know people eyeball it like
Jean what's that all about like is that
your name write your name Jean but it
kind of is Jean that was the best day
name here Jane do you want me to put
another outlet you want me to room take
a shit in your bathroom Jean that was
the carpenter are you sure that's not
that guy then I was the guy that
modified this desk oh shut up he came
back
he's the one took a big shit yeah yeah
yeah they got the the electrician didn't
Jane Jane I do have to say I tried on a
pair of deliberately torn nice jeans
yeah this last week and I was kind of
like I can't pay a lot of money to have
jeans have holes in them it just felt
counterintuitive yeah I agree with this
guy that if you're gonna wear your jeans
they gotta be high they gotta be tight
and they gotta be an act this is the
head coach of the Alabama Crimson Tide
roll tide roll tide Nick Saban his press
conference and a lot of people send this
like do you see Nick Saban talking about
Jesus I just wanted to know how we got
here not to offend anybody out there but
I just walked by some jeans wore out
jeans holes in them no all cut up I just
remember when I was a kid in West
Virginia I was ashamed to go to school
because my jeans were wore out only
because we didn't have any better how
they bond that way I just can't fit how
do we get here
[Laughter]
that's a real dad laughing real football
dad laugh at ya well that's what he's
worried about right now in America the
state of the gene weight range that's
that's what this beef is with the State
of the Union sit we're out genes there
are other much more serious issues going
on in our country right now black guys
would love to fuckin fuck good if you're
a hot black guy fuck me 2395 oh my god
[Laughter]
this guy names help funny thing is else
I could totally understand if Nick Saban
made this video too if he was like oh
they want to fuck me fuck me you got a
play here at Alabama you gotta be
willing to get out there when you gotta
fuck me but I'll take it if you can
really play if you can win me a national
championship fuck me come here that's
how bad he wants it to win absolutely
yeah I think if you pulled some of these
guys some of the coaches the the
big-time coaches aside and you were like
we have to cut off your child's pinkies
and he'll win nitrogen they be like cut
it real quick yeah I think you're right
cuz listening to them talk I mean out of
their minds well on the amount of
sacrifice look I don't know much about
sports I only know what you watch until
it's sometimes I'm interested that Vince
Lombardi documentary he would have sold
all of his children into slavery for
Super Bowls prostitution to win super
all day they're off they're psychos they
become total psychos especially the ones
that win the most there they're just
completely fucking out of their minds
yeah I imagine you have to be to be that
devoted to and like those in that
documentary there like he was unbearable
to be around when they lost like I'm
sure Saban is definitely the same way
yeah well I guess worried about the Jean
situation Americans fucking genes for a
silly kids just cut out completely
pants are sagging oh yours too yeah beep
I got in there you go no I came back
yeah okay let's just loose so we headed
to jail almost
your thug Thug yeah how so much going on
I'm movin you come move yeah fuck me
yeah it gets lonely around the holiday
well I think that would happen is if
somebody was like will guarantee you
like national championships these
homeless guys have to be able to fuck
you and that these guys would low-key
like if they're like as long as one
finds out yeah if it meant definite
national championships yeah yeah I mean
I know some comedians that would do that
for like some is yeah for sure there are
people that do that for parts and movies
wait a minute are we in this did you see
the latest one that was a totally
unexpected which one I mean they're all
kind of unexpected but Jeffrey Tambor I
know he got he is quitting transparent
which is this award-winning show on
Amazon I think it's on and he's won
Emmys and and I think been nominated for
more and the shows really highly
celebrated he plays a trans woman on the
show I guess is the star of the show was
accused of harassing I guess two people
on the show and he just was like you
know I've never meant anything by what I
did it was interpreted a certain way i I
can't see how I could return to the show
so I just quit the show like the star of
the show I mean this is a celebrated
show I guess it's it's almost like yeah
I mean I'm trying to think of like it's
like the star of you know orange is the
new black being like I'm out what
happens to the show you know yeah I
haven't read pacifically the charges
against him so I can't really comment I
mean Al Franken got taken down to yeah
risa another that actually has another
accuser today no yeah this one well his
are like you know it's still harassment
but like the one that today is that in
at the State Fair during a photo he did
you know he's a state senator and would
take his photos with all types of people
a woman said that he definitely grabbed
her but no cheese and then he was like
you know I never grabbed anyone's butt
and she was like no it was not my back
it was not my hip he definitely grabbed
my butt isn't it I was just thinking
today on drive home from LAX yeah
isn't it absurd that in 2017 we have to
tell men like hey guys guys don't pull
your dicks out and masturbate in front
of women oh yeah don't rape don't rape
don't grab to get me fired up that's
inappropriate okay Sarah Silverman came
out finally to speak on the louis c.k
thing because the two of them have been
friends for 20 years and she's got a
show right now - about it does she came
out and was like look it's it's a very
hard thing to be so close to somebody
you know I'm hurt and I'm torn and I you
know I I got her thing was um was
actually pretty thoughtful and
interesting actually hers that I think
unrelated to the specifics is actually
an interesting concept in life because
what she essentially said was can you
love someone mm-hmm that has done
terrible things right like can you love
Heidegger if you know he's a Nazi yep I
guess that would be a version of that so
can you love Charles Manson even though
he's dead now here yeah let's see let's
mic it on that yeah but it would be
interesting like I always you know what
I think about when I like bringing up
Manson is people who are really close
let's say like the rest of us are like
that's a monster but like what if you're
like cousins yelling you know there's
probably some party if it's like
actually like that guy uncle Charlie
yeah uncle Charlie exactly he was always
nice the best pudding right and he was
always a toy for me it was right I mean
like some of them have to be like that
well I think it's not everybody there
are not everybody's all evil that's the
all the time and that's something that
that you understand as you get older
he's a child you process this person's
all good or all evil
yeah you don't look at it as yeah you
look at it as a complicated thing but
people are actually complicated oh you
totally and so you do find sometimes
that people can be good and have done
bad things and then you have to find
some way to deal with that yes well and
also Pamela adilyn whose show better
things on FX I am thoroughly obsessed
with I mean you might show
yeah has ruined television shows for me
because it's so funny and so real and
she's an amazing talent now Lois and her
co-created that show and he co-wrote on
some of the episodes so now the debate
is do they pull the plug on that show
right now there's this great time
article that was like why are you gonna
punish Pamela adilyn for something louis
c.k did is it not a feminist thing to
let the woman have her show yeah why are
you taking her down because of that so
we'll see what happens I hope she gets
to keep that show because my favorite
they pulled the plug on the animated
series that was coming yeah see that's a
bummer because that's a lot of people
that are that's people who are going
into the holidays that love their jobs
because of that it's not it's not fair
you know it's interesting so I saw Ryan
Sickler and Jay Larson yesterday sickles
oh yeah in Houston the crab feast guys
and and Brian and I were going back to
hotel we're talking about Louie we're
talking about Cosby and he goes you ever
seen the video of Cosby coming out of
the courthouse have you ever heard of
this he comes he's coming out just as
he's cleared of some charges and he does
the fucking Fat Albert he does it like
really the fans that are outside the
courthouse if you want to google it try
and find it it's worth it it's worth me
vamping a minute so you can find it yeah
which is just fascinating to me because
you can always tell who's a real
psychopath when they disregard what's
happening in court or they mock or you
know what I'm saying like if you're so
disrespectful to the law like if I was
in court I would not be doing yes this
is it you're gonna die I don't know if
you get here is he's walking out of
court
photographers he just got all he's got
no Georgia it's during deliberations he
hasn't been so he hasn't even been
prettier
this guy started to laugh for sure that
was with him and there's policemen
escorting him out of the building I mean
you really have to be an aloof piece of
sociopathic shit yeah that's pretty
great how are you not worried dude he's
not worried he's doing the Fat Albert
guy start to laugh but how crazy but my
point being like how much of a
psychopath are you to not feel afraid or
feel the severity of what you're eating
or he's just trying to like bring like
lift some of the seriousness of what
he's going you know I mean like of
course so you're like everything is so
serious around you that he's like wow
that's already there's your dad there's
a daddy
Manson uncle Charlie yeah Charlie passed
away how sad are you I am NOT sad that
Charles Manson I'm surprised I'm sure
there's been a Twitter outpouring of
love and support for you on this very
tragic day know he's 83 he's a really
bad guy 83 is not bad for prison life I
gotta tell you that's pretty old for bad
guy locked up for probably 40 some years
a long time and you think he would have
gotten the swastika tattoo removed age
well I'll say that because I saw a
recent photo and it was like drooping
like one of the corners just started
kind of started to melt away looked like
it was like a like a uncoloured Rubik's
Cube falling down on his nose right I
think it's they started as X's right and
then they later turned into swastikas
from what I remember no he had us was
well I read helter skelter and 7th grade
and I think his whole thing was they
gave them X's on their forehead his
followers to be like their xed out of
society and then later it evolved into
the Pleasant swastika okay so I mean hey
just a little I didn't know if you knew
that me and that your
such a big guy that he was a big race
war guy so that's what I thought it was
always Watson right I think it started
as just axes the cult your nutty thing
to say what ensues will raise your
eyebrows to a whole new level what
happens upon being asked if he himself
is Jesus Christ
Benson explains that there are actually
many Jesuses all over the world okay it
is believed by some that so theory yeah
God appears in many forms but what else
is assessment probably isn't what most
people have in mind consciousness number
nine Charles Manson never kills true one
yeah Charles Manson was convicted of
you're right there's an X on this guy's
yeah started I see I know these things
did you read helter skelter when you
were like a teenager
yeah okay I was goth you know I love the
dark stuff you got a read helter skelter
great great great read real just light
toilet read about this thick about his
about the whole the Manson Clan murders
what started it all yes really really
neat reads degree murder but he did not
directly kill even one of the victims
for whom he went to jail rather he
ordered members of his quote-unquote
family to carry out the tate-labianca
murders
so when Manson told Heidi Schulman in
1987 that he quote never killed anyone
there's arguably some accuracy to his
work
however Manson's follow-up statement
makes about as much sense as helter
skelter I don't need to kill anyone I
think it is Manson implying that he can
kill people using his own mind I think
this is the interview where he told her
she was overweight she had fat shame
yeah by Charles Manson yeah
not your type now is he the one that did
he get married you know how some got
married recently
oh oh that's no that's right much
younger woman yeah yeah
was she hot she's she's hot look a lot
of people are hot for him I mean in
other words like compared to him so yeah
on the Charles Manson scale
yeah what do you think's going on there
and the women who choose a serial killer
or just murder as a life partner I mean
if you read helter skelter and you're
like I gotta meet this guy
I gotta marry him that's perfect yeah I
don't know man he's a world-class
fucking psycho yeah he's top of the line
POS oh my man such that he's a drifter
you know he's just a worthless just well
I'll tell you what I remember of helter
skelter so he killed Sharon Tate and
LaBianca other celebrities who's of
famous gorgeous model no that was the
Lansky's wife well right right right
right that's right
raped a teenager yeah what a neat family
anyway she was like seven months
pregnant with their baby yeah yeah it's
pretty horrific he was a failed musician
Manson was a failed artist and he hated
successful artists and successful people
called them pigs said that they you know
they're sad that it's a big setup show
business and Hollywood so he he took it
out on tape that yeah
pretty horrific stuff and then the guy
that created full house bought the
Manson murders home that's real crazy to
buy the house of that happened in be
like he's doing here build a house here
yeah yeah no no no I don't think so no
way that he can get into other people's
heads and influence them to commit
murder in any case it's nothing short of
bonkers I'm pretty good yeah I think now
it's here favorite of the crazy killer I
mean even though he technically is not a
killer but he yeah you know he might
want a writ like who's your fav of the I
don't have a thing from jail homeless or
your thug
do you like Ted Bundy no these are
horrible people Jean yeah but you lovely
I don't love them every night before I
go to bed I hear you watching the
Unabomber Ted Bundy Jeffrey Dahmer
I watched you know stories stories and
watch stories about you know bad people
sometimes yeah who's your favorite I
don't have a favorite there's no
favorite I just like watching stories
about crime
okay there's no favorite all right hey
no no need to get so angry crazy alright
I like Ted Bundy I thought he was the
handsomest of them all you shouldn't
like him he's I don't like it I'm saying
if I had to choose one that I prefer to
learn about he was a smart guy he was
married to UM was he married yeah he got
married in court Bundy was yeah how do
you know so much I talked to this girl
last night about it cuz I there's a bit
I do a bit now about like the wives of
the Weinsteins and the Cosby's of the
world and then Manson came up and she
came up to me on for school you know Ted
Bundy got married in court he did it
himself in court because he represented
himself he did represent himself yeah
yeah yeah his story's real fucked up and
yeah it's pretty bad yeah yeah he's he
was super deceptive and really
articulate for a lot of these guys are
really uneducated and you know Victor
after types like Manson
yeah but Bundy was drifter higher higher
IQ yeah yeah smart dude did he graduate
law school he may and it was College
yeah sure I don't remember yeah it was
fucked up in really fucked up it's all
about mommy these guys get abused by
their mommies and then they end up
hating all the women yeah yeah it'd be
nice to your sons
yeah I'm don't understand like why you
bitches and people mad just because I
say I'm black and incest we gotta say
I'm black why I don't know yeah
ancestry.com says this woman's black I
mean for people listening what does she
look like to you latina
she looks latina to you yeah I don't
know she's just like a pretty brunette
girl like with blondie highlights like a
white girl come on she's a white girl
yeah like you know tan white girl I
guess yeah her eyelashes are alive
anyways were supposed to be equal it's
just in the past people was messed up
and stuff she really has that voice too
if I close my eyes I mean if you're just
listening to this podcast I bet you
swear that's of just a black lady like
it miss Pat was in here she was like Tom
yeah when she thought you were doing her
voice oh yeah yeah your impression I'm
not doing an impression that's a real
clip yeah what did I play for her that
girls really good at black lady voice
yeah that's pretty incredible
jeez it was um it was the farting clip
that's what it was impression the black
people yeah yeah weren't you talking to
me about being trans transracial
trans Fraser that's what this look
that's what this she's transracial yeah
but but she says that her ancestry.com
thing makes her black yeah maybe if she
sees where they go like in your 7%
sub-saharan she's like see I'm African
yeah isn't everybody like point
something yeah pretty much
well not me my blood sciences this girl
is I guess she goes by I'm well Vicki
and she's been getting a lot a lot of
hate yeah I don't I don't think that
that ancestry is going to give you a lot
of clearance there you know like now
like we shall all be one we shall be
look at about race oak they discolor all
day that we should be looked at as one
it shouldn't even be what ancestry.com
say or what or what they look like or
what their hair look like I want to know
so much more about her though
I know like what's her home life like
what's her school life been like yeah
her whole upbringing
when did she completely appropriate
somebody else's vernacular and culture
yeah what's going on yeah it's a lot
about you when did those eyelashes
happen yeah she's got like five layers
of ice teeth great teeth yeah
great teeth but the eyelashes are too
many those are eyelashes are crazy yeah
yeah that's a lot I mean I know it's
cool to fill them in right now women are
getting the
fakies yeah but I think that's like one
layer there five layers too many maybe
for the night out you could do something
but this is just she's just on that
house on the couch videos it should just
be oh then human to be like that but
people wanna be like that well you're
like it that you don't understand every
nail is a different color on her hand
yeah she went for it
is that now ladies are doing one nail a
different flavor right like the the
second-to-last what's this one called
the ring finger I've been seeing that
one they'll do like glitter but to have
every one of them different well that's
kind of Punk
yeah I guess if you like a lot of work
right you got a chain man that that's a
part-time job getting those nails done
all the time and I'm filled getting them
you know glitter eyes and shit that's a
fucking a lot of things a lot of time
yeah it's a lot a lot would you do that
would I get fake nails yeah I guess if
you were a lady sure why not I would do
it I like I like the look but I don't
like the utility of that
yeah there's no utility you can't even
pick your nose how do you wipe your ass
with long nails like that and you see
people like they're touching their phone
and their hand has to go yeah
yeah they can use their phone like it
just disrupts everything yeah I like I'm
sure and clean utility so um where's
this guy yes I can pick my nose better
with no nail the guy that uh that sent
in the machines with in his name is
Jordi yeah and he said he played it for
the crowd yeah you see that yes he sent
it to my Twitter yeah this was a he's in
China look at that
look how many people you know I just
played machines within its arenas it's
an arena that's nuts so he must have is
he the one that sent in the club mix
that's what I'm guessing okay cuz we got
a few a few weeks ago and if all the
haters haters if all the haters went
kind of nuts let me see if I can find
this here while you're looking for that
yeah I will I'm gonna read this email
about dick tattoos yeah dick tattoos was
a topic of conversation and we kind of
wanted to get into how that how somebody
gets their dick tattoos yeah we were
talking about it a few weeks ago right
because it seems very difficult and does
it go to be erect right well also
because what led to it is that some
people have asshole tattoos and some
people have vagina tattoos and then dick
tattoos also exist and we thought about
well how did that artwork get there and
you know is it hard how do you do it so
we had an artist actually wrote in right
yeah he writes so he's he qualifies it
by saying he's not an expert but he's
been tattooing for almost four years he
writes turns out you do not have to be
erect to receive the procedure Christina
was on the right track in thinking of
the stretching of the skin that is the
important part while I personally have
never tattooed a dick I've seen the
procedure and have asked other artists
that have their dick tattooed tattooing
both flaccid and DirectX have
complications for example if you receive
a tattoo on an erected penis at that
time it may only take up a specific area
but as the penis would become more
flaccid the image would shrink
dramatically try blowing up a balloon
and draw on it then deflate it and look
at the image how I've heard they do it
in prisons is to stretch it around a
soda can yeah we heard I also saw a
tennis ball oh that would make sense
yeah that way they have the stability
underneath tattooing scrotums are
another problem entirely you have to
either you have to have either the
client or another artist help stretch
the skin between two hands in the old
bad wing style batwing style to create
flat tissue to work on help this answers
your questions shits definitely push the
farts Uriah thank you you Ryan that's
you do have to stretch it tennis ball is
interesting that is interesting yeah I'm
the source well so okay let's see I have
haters no I was thinking of a husband
thing of this she's retarded song that's
what I was thinking
[Music]
that's what Miley Cyrus
the guy that sent us to us is a Geordie
at Jordan yeah he did so he said he
played it but I was just wondering did
he play a version that he made you know
like that's the part that I was trying
to figure out yeah cuz just let's see
does this say Geordie on it Michael
[Music]
this guy's already at Geordie Jeezy on
Twitter he writes and his in his bio
yeah he's like tweets ending in /jr from
Geordie all the other ones are too you
know how Studio G does it - yeah no I
just I don't see Geordie hater as one of
the producers on one of these I don't
know which one I played
[Applause]
my own songs my introduction to myself
[Music]
so that's from a few weeks ago more
machines within came in we got one here
by it's called freshest fuck machines
within by been okay
more of a chill approach to it right
like a sexy I feel like this is at a
trendy hotel lobby
yes you know I mean like yeah nailed it
509 yeah pool in the lobby and swimming
a mermaid swimming around yeah
then this is a machines within bye Dave
see what this one is scratch your nuts
it's like my crotch area
[Music]
so many different interpretations
look really heartfelt yeah
it's very nice Dave well that's what's
great about the song and the concept is
that it's so high concept it's it lends
itself to constant unfolding constant
interpretation here's one by Daniel
Thomas music
[Music]
yeah scary it's kind of scary and then
here's machines with in there you go
Andrew so a lot of machines with it yeah
pretty impressive man I'm uh I'm very
impressed actually Potamus I'm part of
myself
did what's his name I I thought I saw an
email or a tweet from ob1 saying that he
had sent one in hmm the obi-wan Kenobi
I'll be one cannoli yeah oh here we go
he wrote he did a she's retarded zone
obi-wan did
[Music]
it's really good
hands ahead
[Music]
that's impressive man so good
now I'll be one cannoli is one of the
original creators of music yeah okay now
I see that his thing is in my folder oh
okay I look I searched an email for it
but it's actually the only one yeah it's
in the cheese bridge because I was
looking for it as a machines within song
Wow so it says she's retarded song
obviously very good Jason from
Sacramento also scented she's retarded
song in Obi's was really good he's
always outstanding though he did that
crazy Peter canes up oh my god so good
[Music]
this could be like an iTunes cuz it's so
low-key yeah you could be hearing this
and like nordstrom wait she's retarded
that's why she drools I swear I would
love it so much if anybody could play
that at their place of business if you
work at like a Starbucks doing their - I
used to work in retail I worked at a
place called the maid company doesn't
exist anyway it's basically Macy's now
yeah and Shauna my best friend and I
used to play goth music when we worked
in the young adult section yeah and it
was the most fun to play like Bauhaus
inside of essentially a Macy's yeah and
my boss sorry now and then be like could
you guys change the music in here this
is kind of weird really why I don't know
what this is that's the most fun play
like Joy Division in the juniors
department there's one more so here's a
girlfriend's retarded bye
[Music]
he hid himself
[Applause]
[Music]
together
Pepi yeah a green day you know it's very
good Tom I mean there's a lot of like
said a lot of talented people out there
a lot of interpretations of machines
within and she's retarded you know a lot
of different interpreter education we're
really drawn to that guy yeah yeah that
and the the guy who shit yeah we can't
say but as our special guest coming in
next week yeah there yes that's gonna be
excited see we're gonna play that for
them right we have a special guest
coming up yes well don't cuz you never
know what's gonna I know I know but it's
planned and it'll be really fun really
fun we got a big one yeah okay well
let's not get too - okay you know I'll
be good to do I just had an idea
there's a great Bauhaus song called
she's in parties if anyone out there can
make it she's retarded yeah from she's
in parties I'll be great look this is a
sub Hitler's oh okay I actually have my
dignity
I thought it'd be a great idea to get
drunk in a friend's tattoo study in one
night and get born to fuck tattooed on
my shaft by my boy no I did not have to
get hard for it and the idea being hard
for the dick tattoo sounds cruel and
unusual
mommy jeans was correct in her
assumption that the dick needed to be
pulled and stretched high and tight to
get the crust off and the pain was
normal compared to any other tattoo of
our receipts and all in all was a
hilarious and positive experience also
it makes for a good icebreaker
every time I 69 when he brought try it
out after haters and most importantly
wash yo nuts Jeff from fill er up
Delphia oh he has born you would laugh
or do you think you'd be a this is a
real red it's a red flag it's right but
it makes me laugh yeah and I'd be
friends with him but I don't know if
that's merited you guys not maybe not
but if you were like about to hook up
and you're like someone's dick I don't
know man I'd be like this guy's like
he's too crazy for me like you crazy
he's too wild for me is funny to go that
but I feel like that guy's got way more
life experience than me I feel like I'd
be so boring for him but I mean knowing
you cuz I know you pretty well I feel
like you're
we go to like hold on if this guy's got
born to fuck that to his dick he
definitely is a card-carrying disease oh
yeah yeah I would think that that's what
I think you would think well I yeah cuz
I'd be like well he's clearly had more
partners than me because he's got his
dick tagged I'd assume and he's kind of
slutty no I think yeah slutty and you
might think like this dude has AIDS for
sure that's what you think yeah yeah I
think it because it might look dirty to
me yeah and then I'd be like oh yeah
this guy's got AIDS yeah I would
actually would you think the girl had
AIDS actually got born to fuck on her
puss I would you know I would laugh I
would laugh hard if I saw that and I'd
be like yeah why don't we double bag
this one well it's it's it's a little
more cray-cray on a woman definitely
yeah I mean the dude is nuts
but you also kind of go like this is
probably party guy like this is the guy
he had a few like like the email yeah
yeah and that's what I was just like if
a guy if I met a guy that had that be
like dudes a fun time like he likes to
get a laugh so right but party guy gets
hammered and puts it anywhere exactly
that's the prize the problem yeah yeah
fat chick now I know a chick uh she was
I forget what city didn't show us but
other people were like oh yeah she's got
a butt hole tattoo and I was like I was
really intrigued by that I was like yeah
what's it do you know what it was I
forget I'd have to look it up I mean you
know like search for it cuz it was also
like trending somewhere yeah I mean why
not who no one sees it I forget I forget
the details but I definitely met someone
they got their butt hole tattoos I mean
that again like she was probably she's
probably party girl right now I gotta
ask this question yeah accident how do
you do eyelids
I've seen those tattoos I mean don't
pull it out but then don't they have to
rest the skin on something much like the
penis tattoo you have to rest it on a
the square footage here it's on the next
area yeah make it tight taut remember
when
some casino company gambling place was
paying people to tattoo their foreheads
well people were like looking for - how
that could make like we'll give you
$100,000 and they're like yeah tattoo
like you know fights calm okay scene
Orion or something gambling Empire
fucking forehead I think it was less
than a hundred thousand gene I want to
say it was like 10 or 20,000 Jesus I'm
serious
pressing hey tattoo this on your fucking
face do you know your forehead I'm
saying that yes damn son yeah
damn Oh terrifying that we have a
response here I didn't see this to
response machines within contradiction
oh I have a theory about the lyrical
genius of machines within and the lyric
F the haters F all the haters is it
possible we have just assumed that the F
stands for fuck I'm proposing he may be
saying forgive the haters forgive all
the haters this adds to the credence to
the line this as crystalline much love
no hate maybe he's a mu soup loving
redneck that just loves rapping about
nonsense maybe he's the second coming of
Jesus who happens to be working on his
flow just something I was thinking about
while I was trippin on 10 to 12 benadryl
I got a bad bad bite been from Illinois
that's a really interesting analysis
yeah after haters forgive all the eggs
could be I mean Jekyll lows are about
peace and love and unity so yeah he is a
Juggalo right
yeah yeah that's a that's a really great
theory very thought-provoking uh he has
another I mean that is very
thought-provoking that he's forgiving
the haters I mean that really is Jesus
like could be anything guy has another
submission no yeah
my introduction my song I just made on
Facebook it's called crazy isn't it well
who I go out drop that Bursa for you
crazy isn't hazy isn't it drop that
first drop that first got the knife
crazy isn't it got enough crazy isn't it
crazy isn't yes just just here's such a
specific stuff
you know it's one of the things I would
I was get to is like it's very hard to
get into the rap game and have a style
that's unique to yours like it takes me
back to like when I first got into
hip-hop and like people would sound like
each other and then somebody would come
on you're like wow that sounds so
different I remember like Treach from
Naughty by Nature Busta Rhymes comes to
mind guys that had such a unique
approach to writing mute like the two
lyrics is their cadence
yes flow and this guy I wish I knew his
name also I mean who else sounds like
this crazy isn't it crazy isn't it
shocked at first drop down first I'm the
one that was forgotten crazy isn't it
crazy crazy crazy yeah again he likes
simple yeah I mean here's the genius to
it okay at first I was a little blown
away but then you look at it okay look
at the marketing on this he's got the
bloody for those of you not watching
he's wearing is this a hockey mask yes I
was like that Jason mask 13 yes I mean
yeah he's got the eyes cut out and then
there's like like for Hannibal Lecter
yeah thing yeah and then he's got like a
bloody tarp on uh-huh and he's clearly a
knife holding a knife and he's taping it
in his apartment because you can see the
smoke detector behind him which is
always a key component of these videos
is you gotta do it your shitty apartment
but I have to say for this audience not
ours meaning a particular audience this
is kind of right on the money here crazy
like the theme crazy isn't it
I'm The Forgotten one like it's again
kind of brilliant now does he have the
right needs the right producer we've
said this before I'm try to hook him up
with people I'm still working on it
right the raw I hate to say it but I'm
sticks could be another hit just because
this is the simplicity I reached out to
Pete Rock I've reached out to just blaze
I've reached out to Swizz Beatz I have a
message out to dr. Dre okay I'm just
trying to like what I don't know if he's
West Coast I'm just trying to get the
right guy Timbaland got an email I know
we're trying to get him in the right
because we realize what we have what we
have here is other level
I'm being serious like I think I know I
sense you're joking
this could be a big song like for the
people who like music like guar or you
know whatever that late the the Insane
Clown Posse people like that like that
music yep this is this falls right in
line with how crazy crazy innocent
innocent victims victims crazy isn't it
crazy isn't it innocent incidents I'm
kind of brilliant bro
I mean this is a whole genre of like
rock metal what I don't know what it's
called but what's it called the like
horror metal or something like what is
Guara I get the feeling that it's all on
the spot off the cuff - I don't think he
writes anything down like jay-z just
like jay-z yeah that's exactly what I'm
thinking of it gets in the studio and
yeah this is what I'm gonna talk about
today ah ah turn on my headphones ah
yeah crazy isn't it crazy first chop
that first second path second path crazy
isn't crazy isn't it
much love no hate no hate no hey no hey
no hey nice loud no hey bar slum though
hey so it's cool in this place so drop
first
crazy isn't it yeah not bad really good
I'm impressed
I'm past crazy isn't it I was Nick sorry
his name is Nick see playing some of the
you okay I dropped over from Qatar the
killer Klowns YouTube okay that's his
name
I owe it so this guy registered it's 140
BPM added a simple drum loop and nothing
else in my mind was blown so this guy
actually took what we heard and just
kind of messed with it a little bit just
kind of tweaked it like you said
basically got with a good producer he
said the perfect cadence with the entire
this guy's really really working on his
flow no bullshit he might be the realest
rapper in the game today you know yeah a
little more love on that beat it's going
in the right direction though I like
where this is going it's a good point I
mean it really is interesting Wow a
cultural Brown question do you feel shit
the shower is a cultural cornerstone for
some variants
since both Tina and Adam Carolla engaged
in the backwards ritual furthermore do
different nationalities have their own
unique Braun time rituals such as
Italians like myself bringing the tour
being notorious back to front wipers but
thanks a bunch genes John I didn't know
Italians were like that I didn't know
that either yes Sebastian yeah a
spokesman for Italians I will say my
Indian stepfather when he came to
America and the 70s did not know that
you could sit on our Western silence or
toilets and he squatted on our toilets
until his roommate walked in on him
shitting one day like that and was like
bro you don't have to do that you sit on
it you sit on it so that's a different
way I would say that's crazy he stood on
the seat he stood and squatted because
that's how you do it in the old country
you know mm-hm there's just a hole in
the ground you ever shit on there in the
eastern world never yeah I haven't shit
I'd pee though
want to experience it no that's you know
what sometimes people go you want to
experience this new thing and you go
yeah I'm all good on experiences I'm all
good but here's the good part about
squatting is that it does give you a
cleaner break yeah I've heard that the
the clean up is far less it's more
natural it is and this it's the whole
concept behind that the squatty potty
which the whole concept is like we're
made to shit that way so I understand
that yes what happens is like the
further like if you stand up and squat
down that is how your body is designed
to release shit sure you know your your
knees go up your your asshole hangs down
low sure it's just like a perfect escape
valve for xscape I think yeah for your
for your bowels yeah and that whole
thing is that like on the squatty potty
is that you're sitting down and your
feet are elevated so it's pushing you
know it's making you kind of you're
seated but you're in that position more
like childbirth they push your knees up
to that position
I'd rather do that though then go for
the full experience don't need it I
don't need it I don't really like I
don't need the the thigh you know what I
mean like it's got it's not relaxing to
me to have to squat like that I don't
want to do it I want to chill when I'm
on the toilet yeah how am I supposed to
order my groceries and stuff online do
my shopping I'm squatting squatting no
no come on how to do it so you got a
good one well we were talking the other
day yeah about your dad my most favorite
person on the planet and we were you
were doing your top dog impression for
me the other day and I just I don't know
would you be can I talk to top dog a
little bit you're trying to roleplay
with me yeah okay sure top dog because
we're talking about a time when you
would be single like what would happen
if your wife passed away before you meet
people date okay I probably wouldn't
marry again but I would go on dates
I'd have my fun you know like like big
debts and I like blondes and probably
I would have my fun but I probably I
probably would marry good yeah if you're
gonna take a woman out on a date what
would you do with her
I like movies okay I like movies I like
dinner probably say would you like come
come inside after are you a good public
speaker
very natural yeah some people just have
it I've always I get people I you know
I'm very thoughtful and I just know I
know how to make people laugh and I know
how to engage people and entertain is
very good very natural is exactly how he
is the toys answer the honey person his
answer I'm actually repeating an answer
just called that's him just in the story
of his own remember at the blonde jokes
era that we were doing all the blonde
jokes with him he just loved that I
loved it yeah that guy oh my god
so speaking of like dad parents we got
so excited last week a potential of this
about how when my dad turned 70 I kept
saying it at that get together with my
parents I kept asking my mom she's got a
16 on my dad before we turned 70 the
last night of being 69 she was a quiet
no idea no idea so we asked you guys to
ask your folks if they would like ask
your mom if she's gonna 69 hurt your dad
I'm 17 right before is 7 yet
and some of you really came through
thank you for that all is done
are you think you'll be with him when
he's 70 you think that's a possibility
do you think the night that he turned 70
you guys are gonna 69 she's so mad
that's exactly what I wanted she shut
down
we got Justin thank you so my god that
was so funny please keep doing this 69
here's an audio one that came in 69 that
you give them a 69 on that day that is a
sky from Michigan it'll work and then
use everyone this is a different one
i'ma say yes yes this one's got sent in
today where did you forward it to my me
where's that okay I see it I see it all
right
oh here we go if I can open this I love
how upset it makes moms of course I'm
Samantha could you get it I think it's
so funny it's so silly that your son
would ask you something so crazy yeah it
would be from your mom's podcast at
gmail.com i forward it to you I see it I
see it I'm trying to get it to open if
all the haters oh god it's so funny I
wish my mother were alive so I could ask
her that because I don't even think she
knew at 69 was 69 Vaati 69
my mom definitely didn't see my 30th and
my 40th and so far and I said I remember
40 I don't remember the 50s at all but
this was my 40th no your most recent one
with 70 right my most recent blast on Oh
milestone yeah
70 yeah mom first for dad's 70th
birthday did you guys like 69 it's all
great did you guys 69 dad celebrate we
celebrated and this is the email already
my boyfriend's 30th birthday and then he
asked his mom and dad about that that
came from Samantha that was the dad got
it yeah the mom was like what that was
amazing did she say that she knew what
it was yeah she's like I think I know I
can't believe you're asking that that
was really great
so yeah 69 Astrid my god here's another
silly question yeah six-fingered
question let me get into it some people
have six fingers on each hand how do
they decide which finger is the middle
phone God are they better at guitar and
saxophone and fingering butts
numerically yes they are but sometimes
you can have too much of a good thing I
think all three of us know how good
fingering can be too how do they count
to ten is their base ten system of
counting based on 12
they said give me 24 minutes instead of
give me 20 minutes when they're late
obviously you're the machines well then
I trust you with these issues then I'm
forever someone with only 10 shitty Wow
yeah I have seen your medicine a 600
person I've only seen it in that movie
my name is inigo montoya I've seen it a
few times
shut up aye sir I swear who I've met
people with them I've met people with
six toes also yeah yeah they have like a
little extra digit on the side there Wow
yeah apparently I've actually saw
something about you know evolution why's
that one day we won't have pinky toes
I've heard this they said that there's
no you know that you you eventually will
not have them because there's not really
you don't get a lot from I'm good I feel
like you get balanced from them
obviously right I would think so extra
balance no and they say your pinkies are
kind of arbitrary as well however no I
don't you need them to play piano or the
flute I don't know but yeah anyways
that's a really good question if any six
fingered people are out there or know of
600 people will you ask them if they
will just refer to things in 12 or
whatever they have six and five to the
oh it's got to be a little loaded
question right get my water okay there's
a lot of behind I think it's a really
interesting question here we go
this uh super what is this okay this
says from blue been here he says uh this
guy what does this guy do
yeah he's a professional he failed
himself up sealed himself shot what
Christina have you ever had any close
close calls like this on television or
on stage like early on in your career so
let's see what they're probably say yeah
she's actually the police I mean nobody
doesn't do anything okay school trick
pony he's nervous of the resit
he doesn't do anything nobody's not
going to it's over oh but all he does
I'll tell you he does he is good like
that okay okay you just owe me I don't
like it I don't like it
he's got really nervous I don't like it
next clip can you watch it no well he
doesn't throw up I don't want to watch
it I don't like it but he doesn't I
don't like it you know I don't like it I
don't I'm not gonna watch they're not
gonna get me what you think I'm stupid
then I'm gonna watch the clip with puke
in the title no no okay come on I'm not
putting on my headphones because I know
you're gonna you're gonna play the audio
do you want to see this no I'm not don't
lie to me I'm not I opened a new folder
so this guy is kind of the Bert of the
golf world his name is John Daly I don't
know if you ever heard of him he's
pretty famous check out what he goes
through in a day no no he goes through
you gotta listen it's over I promise I
promise look Oh fuckin you've calculated
bitch okay just got to hear this you've
calculated that you smoked up to 18,000
cigarettes a year I don't know if you're
still smoking that much but how long
have you smoked that much for got
started smoking when I was 19
smoked for almost 29 years I smoked
about the same as the book two packs to
two and half packs a day any desire to
stop I know he looks good I mean yeah so
this guy's like legendary for being like
the partying golfer can't he actually
won some major events many years ago but
he had a lot of alcohol assurance I mean
you can tell by the bloated face the bad
under-eye bags the red complexion the
the white hair is really a nice touch to
red skin I mean he looks like a walking
bag of shit so that's what I would
expect
and then he drapes himself in the
American flag jacket like a total
lunatic I mean
this guy looks so bad but Jesus Christ
how'd he even consume that much soda in
the day yes I used to drink anywhere
from 12 to 20 diet cokes a day how I
went to McDonald Street four times a day
for me they always had the best fountain
drink found Diet Coke we do
I don't know cuz I don't drink water I
hate water I cannot stand to drink water
you don't drink water at all Rich Beem
and some of the guys they call me camel
cuz I don't drink water I never drink
water on tour yeah it means you know it
even means on those hot days when
they're out on the golf course walking a
golf course is 95 degrees out takes
fucking three and a half hours he's just
like hey did you hand me a diet coke
dude just piss has to be like brown his
insides just have to be a fucking
ashtray I'm sure man all of it
how old are you used to eat McCullers
quite a bit
I like McDonald's Burger King McDonald's
Taco Bell all of them then what's quite
a bit I could I used to go to eat like
two Big Macs two or three cheeseburgers
chocolate shake and I our regular coke
back then you know before I started
drinking diet coke my cooks very healthy
and sitting pretty easily I mean is
sitting in a sitting
ah damn he said to Big Mac couple
cheeseburgers milkshake and a coke
how's he so skinny from that he's not
that skinny I'm so deceptive right now
the angle diet when you won the British
Open I don't think it was that bad I
think when I won the British says only
85 I thought you were eating joking you
were doubting like multiple facts of mmm
chocolate cookies and chocolate muffins
and oh yeah what's wrong with that but
only way like 225 when I won the British
but see I wasn't drinking you know this
guy's a golfer yeah this just goes to
show like how little athleticism is
involved in golf
yeah well they're really skilled but
yeah you could be a piece of shit like
all right like baseball too can't you be
kind of a slug you can be if you could
do that one thing bowling yeah I did you
have that joke yeah
bowling darts bowling poker and darts I
think the Triple Crown of lazy yeah yeah
let's see this guy's just got a death
wish you got to see this guy
but I get it I like McDonald's I really
do I like that shit too
yeah this is him I mean Jesus Christ
he's a masked man but he's like a he's a
known mess I mean look at that so who
was she
big who she belly up real real drink oh
and the hair doesn't help you know he
but he was known for was just like
crushing a ball to you do it three
hundred fifty yard drives that's a
toughie he is the Burt of the golfing
we're all we totally is
I wish Burt smoked I really do
this guy is just a walking turd even got
even got a like Burt played golf
shirtless a few times I mean yeah it
look like no no yeah he's the party guy
you know you know I mean and that is a
cute thing until you're this guy's age
and then it's not cute then you're just
suicidal you know right well Burt's
trying to you know change I'm he ran he
ran a fucking half marathon I heard I
really was hoping he'd get hurt but he
did finish
he finished yeah he finished in like a
decent time too it's amazing
I know I've never run anything like that
half marathon I would never do it
couldn't pay me I mean let's be honest
at marathon a shit okay how many miles
is a 13.1 that's a lot no it's not to
merit marathons are what's up you're
running a half marathon okay okay okay
I mean I've never run 13 khun's miles
consecutively in a day have you hey man
let's play some half-court basketball
why there's a full court here okay you
do a half that sounds like you're
throwing down the gauntlet I'm just
saying that ain't shit that's all I
wanted to say that's it
damn coach late to go over he says
you're gonna lose at least 60 70 pounds
before you play for this golf team and I
weighed like one I weighed like 230
maybe 235 well and then in addition to
that you hated cigarettes at the time
but didn't he start you a cigarette he
used to smoke marlboro lights he said
just start smoking here have a cigarette
my coach told him a coach told him to
start smoking his eyes are so puffy oh
yeah like you know what I mean they look
so much bulkier and it's just from toxic
oh yeah man this guy's really been like
the puffiness is really de bloat I mean
the guy's loaded I'm five almost five
eleven I'm supposed to weigh 184 pounds
in my height I just don't see it I'm
big-boned you know I'm not a I'm not a
skinny bone I have I have some of the
big arms big legs it'd be hard for me to
feel healthy 184 pounds yeah I've heard
that before
hello he cuts his bangs - it's like what
your mother used to put a bowl on your
head and then cut around the ball didn't
you get a bowl cut course did she's an
actual Bowl my mother no my mother was a
hairdresser oh she was oh yeah before I
think in Canada she was cutting here and
in the US so she knew she went to
cosmetology school you've got to see
this you're gonna die yeah so this guy
is outside a club and he sees alleged
piece of shit are Kelly and this guy's
got some mental problems but he's like a
big fan so he so he's got yeah you know
yeah he's touched autistic artistic art
yeah well it's funny though
I believe I can touch the sky I think
about it every night and day so he's a
better singer than I am
well yeah and here's the thing we the
big reveal is that I guess he posted
this hilarious people were really mad
because that fan would that was just
singing there is autistic yeah and so
people got really upset that he was
basically mocking them saying that he's
high so then I don't think he was maker
I think he was laughing good fun well
yeah he was clowning the kid but in a in
a box candles if you want I don't have
time to go into the full depth of it now
if you really want to feel like somebody
is allegedly a repugnant piece of shit
you should read in depth about r.kelly
yeah the case made for him being a
horrific human being is pretty
substantial yeah like we're talking
borderline or actually just go ahead and
call it allegedly I have to keep saying
that sure kidnapping yes I've heard
these stories like mind control taking
phones away of people giving them orders
of when they could bathe go to the
bathroom set like and that was and
there's like it's not like once like as
if that's you know a not a lot but like
many many cases
oh it's been over the years from what
I've heard and and he's into the
fifteen-year-old yeah yeah a whole bunch
these are this is not like an
underground thing these are published
things but I've never seen nothing
really I mean he did have a obviously
that serious case that he beat but then
what I'm talking about is he
since then and it's documented in
newspapers maybe he's maybe he's thrown
some cash at it I'm sure he's thrown
some cash yeah throw some cash at those
rang I was just gonna say can I ask you
something since I feel like you're more
familiar with this culture than I am
what's the deal with black dudes wearing
two diamond earrings Jonah's handling I
thought one was cool
but I thought two meant you're gay like
that's gay oh no no back culture no no
no no Romanian culture no no it's all
it's all about doubling up on it it's
been that way for a while I feel like so
like what kind of black guy wears the
two earrings versus the one dude I'm
saying well I mean the one thing I feel
like hasn't been a thing in 25 years
really so it's been it's been too and I
just haven't noticed yeah kinda like the
bigger the diamonds like the you know
just dudes that just straight up stuntin
on people right now like those are big
look at the size of that gorgeous yeah
core gist and like some dudes will buy
the fake ones just because like who
knows we were talking about this the
other day yeah you're like the guy in
the mall isn't wearing like real jewels
no no I didn't know that I did you go
out and you see like people usually a
crazy jewelry there's a 99% chance it's
fake you know yeah but then if you're
are Kelly you have our Kelly money
there's a possible there's a possibility
of two things one that he has the real
thing but like keeps it in a safe and
use it when he feels like this is a
special event and then he'll use the
fake or that it's just always real you
know I bet it's always real this guy's
got so much money he's got shitload of
money
he's very talented yeah he is yeah but
like the double earrings thing and I
think especially its teeth are nice in
the last ten years
in the last ten years the fusion the
coming together of hip-hop and pro
sports has been about light and like
when being flashy has become like more
celebrated maybe last 15 years you see a
lot more you see double massive diamond
earrings on rappers
hip-hop you know some producers you see
it on pro athletes now the the athletes
they don't work during the games do they
there's been guys that where usually you
see necklaces during the game like gold
chains you know and and usually it'll
pop out you know like in in football
though after a play you can see
sometimes the necklace falls out and
then they tuck it back in earrings
usually no that's a definite no but like
then there's this football player Julio
Jones who I guess he went he was wearing
his crazy diamond earrings when he was
out on a boat and lost him and then like
old people like if you can get him for
me I'll give you this much money you
know to return there were a hundred
thousand dollars 100 grand on earrings
so I don't know what you know how many
carats that is but that feels like too
much to spend on earrings personally I
mean yeah I don't know it seems a little
too much seems excessive
coming up to me like a fan you know
didn't seem like he had autism to me at
all he wasn't he was he didn't I was an
artist at all that's what I saw I
actually saw it being in the spirit of
him having fun with the kid I mean yeah
he didn't have to like play with that
guy he was being fun
well now it's cool I thought I was cool
issued a hundred dollars on the streets
and the next morning they say I gave
them three dollars
it's just too much guys you know let me
do my work and it's obviously people
travel blackballed me in this join my
career I understand that but you know
but then just like our favorite lyricist
I got this one thing that's safe I don't
tell God about my problems I tell my
problems about my god I love my fans I
thank y'all for supporting kales
continue to if you want to tal that
haters I love you because you inspire me
mmm all the haters use them as fuel
inspiration forgive all the haters so
give all the haters oh my god I gotta
make that call okay yeah I'd make that
call Jean make that go make that call
make that go all right we got to close
out this show don't forget huge sale in
the merch store machines within Santa
Clause stuff Santa Claus wears jeans hat
sweaters a bunch of stuff out if you
haven't seen mother and Fuhrer yet on
Netflix
check it out Kristina P our very first
Netflix one-hour special and yeah we'll
see it the live shows anything else gene
no thank thanks for listening thank you
listening guys we'll see you next week
bye gene
[Music]
I always be blessed she'd stay high
inside cuz I never be sad at all while
and when I went through the traffic
almost soupy up thank you for has been
terminated uh HD you could tell me
always do a big like for Christ village
that far ahead
don't fuck up my pronouns he said but I
asked for booze that goes down
you've already know that my phone's got
the crew married my mom got divorce in a
week
shout out to Ellis and shout out to Pete
shout out to Bristol for ranking my shit
come when I hug tell the batter that's
it
can fuck Vargo's have become a good clue
stay holding my thoughts every time I
make love a fuck you doing man
[Music]
we got down we take some softer